This course will teach you how to deploy
10 of the most popular types of apps
on the three most popular cloud providers. So
if you want to learn to deploy a specific type
of app, this course is for you. In this video,
we'll create a Docker container for each of these
apps. And we'll deploy the container to assure AWS
and Google Cloud, the result will be the same for
all apps. So check the timestamps of this video
to select your favorite language or framework,
and then select your favorite deployment platform.
So let's start deploying this apps. In this video,
we will create a production container for this
react app. And we will deploy it to Google Cloud,
AWS, and the zoo. So let's start. First,
I'll create a file called Docker file. And,
of course, make sure you have installed Docker in
your machine. And in the Docker file, we have to
start from the container itself, what type of
container will it be, and we'll start with from
this container will be a nod container.
And here I will specify the version of not so
I will pick 15.4. And I will name it as build.
I will explain later why I named it like
this. So let's start with this container,
we have to specify the working directory. I'll
call it up. So you can put whatever you want here.
And let's copy the packages the JSON to that
working directory. So this means we have to copy
this package dot JSON dot mean,
so the working directory here.
So a lot of star here. The star means that we
cannot anything in between package and JSON.
This means that we'll copy package JSON and also
package lock that JSON. So we copied those files,
then we have to run npm install. So this
is self explanatory. So we have NPM already
installed in the container because we are using
a node environment here. So that's why this is
important. After we installed all
the packages, we have to copy again,
all the files to the working directory. So this
means all the other files, we have to copy them
to the working directory. And then we have
to build the container. So run NPM run build.
So if we go to package JSON, we have
a build script here. And what this
will do it it will create a distribution
folder so let's run that command NPM run build.
So we can visualize that folder.
So we have built a folder here
which will have all the necessary files and we
completed the first stage. So this will be a multi
stage Docker build, which means that we will have
another stage so we have all these files inside
this Docker container but we need only the build
folder so there is no need to keep all of them
we can have a smaller container.
And to do to do that we have to
add another from here and this container will
have nginx so I'll pick the latest version.
So if I want the latest version, I will just
add nginx here, or I will add the one point 19.
And in this nginx container, we need to add
here I will create another directory nginx.
And here I'll create a file nginx.com.
And here I'll paste this configuration So
there's a lot of text. But you can copy this file
on the source code in the video description. So
this is required to access the file index dot HTML
directly here. So the build is index, HTML, HTML
and all the JavaScript files that we need. So we
have to copy this file to this nginx container.
So copy nginx nginx.com, to etc nginx nginx.com.
So we added our own nginx configuration, then
in the second step is to add the build folder
to the nginx. html. So that's why we named this
as build here. So here, I will copy from built.
So this is a command from this container here,
which has this build folder will copy up build,
we specified the working directory to be up. So
it will make sense that the build folder is up,
built. And we have to copy this from user user
share nginx. html. And that's it. So this is our
Docker container to build this react
app in production. So to run this,
simply run Docker build, I will specify the name
for this container. So to specify the name for
the container, you have to add here minus deep.
And the name of the container, I'll specify to
up when we need the context, which is this
directory. So we specified with dot. And
that's it. So we'll build this Docker file. And
we will assign it a name to up. Let's build it.
So it's building. Now the container has been
built now is ready to be deployed. But before
we deploy it, let's see if this is running fine.
But by running it on the browser, so to do it,
run Docker run our app, but we have to
specify our port. So minus b here, and
the port of our container will be
ad. So this will run on port 80.
And this is a part of our browser, so our boot ad
it will work on my machine. But if it doesn't work
on your machine, you can put another port like
a day date doesn't matter. So I'll put ad here.
And this will run our Docker container.
Now, I'll go to my browser around here,
localhost, just localhost, because 80 is the
default port. And we can see our react up. So
we created a Docker container to be deployed now.
And now let's deploy it out close this ID because
we don't need it anymore. In this video, we will
create a simple node app and we will deploy it
to AWS Azure and Google Cloud. So let's create
it I will open my terminal and write NPM in it.
So Oh, Pika everything by default,
and then I will install Express.
So I'll create also an index. So
JavaScript file index.js. Here I will
get the Express so const Express
is equal to require Express.
Then I will get so Okay, the
first up is equal to express
and up a get request to The main
road all of the function here
that it will have a request and the response. And
this will be very simple, I will just do response
send. Hello, world. That's it. So, super
simple. In the end, I will listen to Port 80.
So I want to start this up. So this is self
explanatory, but I will start this up via a
Docker container. Because of the Port 80 is just
localhost. And it may conflict your browser. So
let's create a Docker file.
The Docker file will be very simple. So we need
a node environment. And the version is 15.4.
So we will specify a working directory, I'll call
it up, then we will copy the package Jason. So
package dot JSON dot min sir, it will copy to
the working directory here. So in short, is dot
a lot a start here. So this will take package
JSON and also biggest minus log that JSON.
So if we do it like this, it will copy
both of these, then we'll run npm install
because we get from the node environment, then
I'll copy all the files there. So the first dot
means all the files here, and the second.is
the working directory, then the last command
is not index that j s. And that's it. So this
is our Docker file. To build this Docker file,
we have a first make sure to have installed
Docker and then around Docker build,
we need to specify a name for this Docker build,
I will call it up. So this is a command to
pick a name for the Docker container. And then
we need dot here, which means this context here,
so it will select this Docker file. And now
it's building once it is completed, let's
so it is completed. And now to see
the app on our browser or on Docker
around, we need to specify the
port which we need to run. So
80 is a port inside the Docker container. And then
is our app. So in our browser output for eighth.
So if we run this command and go to localhost Port
8888, we will see HelloWorld here. So this is our
container. And now let's get
this up and deployed to AWS,
Azure and Google Cloud. Now close also with
window because we don't need it. In this video,
we'll create a Docker file for this view
up and deploy that Docker container to AWS,
Google Cloud and Azure. So let's
start. Let's create a Docker file.
So to build this app, we will use
the multistage builds in Docker,
I will explain you what is that So first,
we have to start from node. And I will put
the version of node to this version.
And I will name this as build.
So I'll explain later why I named it like this.
First, let's specify the working directory.
I'll name it up. Then, let's copy package the JSON
to up. So to the working directory. The second dot
means this working directory I would love to start
here. So this will get the package JSON and also
baggage log that Jason. So after we
got those files, were run npm install
So to install the node models event will copy all
the files to the working directory. So all these
files will, it will be copied to this working
directory. And then we run NPM run build. So
this will build this view up to distribution
folder. So if we run this command NPM run build,
we'll see a distribution
folder will be created here.
So this is a folder, and it will
have an index that HTML index etc. So
now what I will do is old, add another from
here. And I will get nginx version one point 19
why I'm adding another from here.
So this is multistage building so,
so we don't need all these folders anymore inside
the Docker container inside the Docker container,
we need only the distribution folder,
so only this folder. And to do that,
first we have to create the first stage, which we
have all the files and the distribution folder.
And then we create another from here. And first,
we need an nginx file. So we'll use nginx here,
let's create directory nginx. And
inside I'll create a file nginx.com.
Here, I'll paste this code. So it's a lot
of code. But I'll provide the link in the
description of this video. So you can get this
code. And to copy that nginx file we are on copy
nginx nginx.com, we have to
copy it to the EDC folder nginx
nginx.com. So we'll put this
file where when will copy from
build. That's why I named it like this. So once
we finish, we have a reference for this build.
So from that build, we want only the distribution
folder. So in the app distribution folder.
That's why we named also the working directory up
so it is in up and also distribution folder. We'll
copy it to user share nginx. html. And that's it.
So in the end, we'll have a smaller container just
containing HTML and JavaScript and CSS files. So
let's run this container. To run this container.
Make sure first to have installed
Docker and run Docker build,
we need to specify the name for this container our
call it up. So if you want to name your container,
whatever name you want, with minus D
and the name here, then I'll put a dot
which means that it is this folder here and
it will select this Docker file. So with this
our Docker is building. Let's wait till
is completed and so it is built now
anger to sit on the browser, we need
to run it. So around Docker around,
we need to specify a port. So to see it on our
browser output this port to our browser. And this
app will run on port 80 since we are using
nginx here, and then we need the name of our
container which is up so let's run this and is
running now. So if we go to localhost Port 8888
we'll see the view up. So this is
our container. And now I will close
this window now because we don't need it anymore.
Now let's deploy This container. In this video,
we'll create a production readiness JS Docker
container. And we'll push that container to AWS,
Google Cloud and ashore. So let's start. First, I
want to change in main.ts, the port here to add,
because all our containers will start with the
Port 80. And now let's create the Docker file. So
also make sure to have installed the Docker in
your machine. So let's start the build. So we
need to start from the node environment and output
to the version 15.4. And I'll name it as build.
So this is a multi stage Docker
build. I will explain that later.
First, let's begin with the first stage. So let's
begin with node 15.4. And what do we want to do
here, let's specify a working directory up. And we
want to copy package that JSON to the app. So dot
min. So this working directory, also, I would
love to start here. So if I had to start here,
this will get package JSON and also package log
that JSON. So I added to the biggest the JSON now
run NPM installed. Since we are from the node
environment, this NPM command is available.
After we finished that, we want to copy everything
to the working directory. So this first dot
means all the files here, the second dot means
this working directory after we finish around
NPM run build. So with this, we build this
nest j s up. So let's run NPM run build here
and see what it does generate. So this will
generate this folder here. So as we can see,
we have a dist folder. And here we have
all the necessary files. So in order to
run this in production, we have to have this
dist folder, and we don't need the other files.
That's why we do like a multistage build, because
we will create another node environment here
from node 15.4. Also. And in this node
environment will specify again the
working directory up. So don't confuse this with
this because there are two different containers.
Then we'll copy also the here I will
copy only the package JSON actually
will run npm install, but
we need only the production
packages. So if we go to package JSON, we have
dependencies and dev dependencies, if we run it
like this, we will install only the dependencies.
So there are fewer packages here. And
this not package will be smaller than this one.
Of course, because we have less packages, then
we'll copy from built will copy the
distribution folder. So up disk.
So up is the working directory here. This
is the folder that we just generated.
And we'll copy that to the
dot means our up here, this
so we will copy the distribution folder there.
This distribution folder has a JavaScript file.
So this needs also not models. And that's
it basically. So in the end, we'll run
the command MPM around start broad.
So this is a smaller version of
this one, because this will this other
container will have only the distribution folder
and not models, but only the production packages
so we don't need all these vials. So we created
the production rate the next JS up, let's around
it. So to run it, simply run Docker build,
we need to specify the name of the container, I'll
call it up. So if you want to name a container,
you put minus D and the name of the container.
And dot means this folder, and it will select this
Docker file. So if we run this, it will build
our app. No, let's wait till it's completed.
So it is completed. Now this container
can be pushed to the to the cloud.
But first, let's test it. So to test
it, we have to run it. So Docker
run. And we have to specify the port the port
inside the Docker container is 80. But in our
browser, we can put any port we want. So output
this port, and the name of the container is up. So
we can run our container like this, as we see is
running successfully, and we can go to localhost
8888. And we can see HelloWorld here, so the
container is running. Now we need to push this
production container to the cloud. And I will
close this ID here because we don't need it. In
this video, we'll create a production ready Docker
container for an Angular app, then we'll push
this container to AWS as your Google Cloud. So
let's start. First of all, create a Docker file.
Make sure also to have installed Docker in your
machine. So we need the environment here. So we
need the node environment. And the version that I
will put here is 15.4. And I'll name it as built.
So, we will do a multistage Docker build, I will
explain that later. First, let's focus from this
node. This part here, we want to build our
app. Let's start with the working directory.
You can name it whatever you want, I will call
it up event will copy package that JSON to the
working directory. So, I will add also the start
here. So this will copy package the JSON and also
package log that JSON this dot means this working
directory. So, once we have those files there,
we are on NPM installed and since we are using
the node the container we have NPM available.
So, after we install it, then we
need to build it to production.
So, before I run anything here, I will I want
to make a change who we have energy bill here
in our scripts, but if we want to build to
production we have to add prod here. So,
what I will do is I will add a new script
prod and this will be mg build prod like this.
So this will be easier. And now here
I will run the command NPM run probe.
So this will build our up to production.
So I will run that command here also.
And let's see what files it
does generate shop. Now we will
learn why I named it like this. Because once we
run NPM run prod it will create some files here.
And when don't need the these files anymore,
we need only the distribution folder.
So we created the build. So not sure why my app
doesn't get the files doesn't matter. So let's
add the new from here and this time
we want have not but I will add nginx
and the version will be one point 19.
So here we want to read not we will simply
serve the HTML files which I need to refresh,
not sure why they reload. So we have the
distribution folder here. And we can see,
we have index HTML and these files. So
it's located in the distribution folder,
angular Docker. This is the name of my project,
by the way, you can name your project, whatever.
So now we are at nginx. We need also a directory
here nginx. And I will add here a file nginx.com.
Here, I'll paste this nginx code.
So I will provide this code in the
description of this video. And let's go
to the Docker file. I'll copy copy here
nginx nginx.com. And we'll copy that to
edisi nginx nginx. That calm. So dot here.
So we have copied that file in this other
container. And now, we will use this build here.
So as I said before, we don't need this virus
anymore, we need only the distribution folder,
since it will serve the index HTML file with
these JavaScript built files. So for that,
we will copy it from build will copy we have the
working directory is up here. So from up this
and this, there's another folder here, which
is angular Docker, in my case, Angular, Docker.
And we'll copy that to throw a lot of flesh
just in case to user share nginx. html.
So this way, this was a bigger container,
since we did not models and all these files,
but this one has only HTML and JavaScript files.
So the smaller container is only going nginx,
which is serving only this HTML file. And we need
this engine x, we needed to because when we go to
a specific URL, we want to redirect all
of them to the index dot HTML. So this is
this location. Otherwise, we'll get an error. So
this is the Docker file. And now let's run it.
So to run this Docker file, right Docker build,
we need to specify a name for this Docker file
for each Docker container. I will specify the not
to app but you can name it whatever you want. And
we need to build this Docker file, so we have to
add it as a dot here. So now is building Let's
wait till it's completed. So it failed. Because
I forgot one line here between npm install and
NPM, run prod, which is to copy all the files to
the working directory. So my better. So this will
copy all these files to this working directory.
And then we need to build to production. So now
that we fixed the problem, let's run it again.
So now it was built successfully. And now this
container is ready to be pushed to the cloud. But
first, let's see on our browser. So to sit on our
browser, we have to run the container. So Docker
run, we need to specify the port. So the port
inside the container is 80. In our local host,
we can put whatever port you want. So I will put
a date a date so and then we need the name of our
container, which we named it up. So that's
it. If we're on this and go to our browser,
let's go to localhost 8888. And we'll see
the Angular app running. So this was our
container that was built. Now let's push this
container to the cloud in our clothes. This
ID because we won't use it anymore. In this
video, we'll create a production ready, go File,
and we'll push it to AWS, Google Cloud and as your
so let's start, first, let's run, go mod in it.
We'll call the project, Docker doesn't
matter. So also go to a go fiber
framework, we want to use this framework, but
we will just copy the HelloWorld part thought
will create main that go file. And so enable
integration here, let's create a go File, main.
The package, so I'll base it
here. This is our main go file.
And, of course, let's also get this fiber
model here. So go get this. So we got that we
either did on our go mod. So we also got some so
these are important because we need to add them
to Docker. So this is our goal up. Now let's
create a Docker file. So I'll create a file here.
Docker file. Also make sure to have Docker
installed in your machine. So now here, we need to
specify the environment which this container will
be billed. And this will be a golang container.
So I'll put the version here, which is a
latest version for this time is one point 16.
And I will add the Alpine here, which is a
version of Linux, which is the smallest one.
And now let's specify a working directory,
I'll call it up but you can name
name it whatever you want. So the
working directory is up now let's copy go
mod to the app directory. So this other dot means
that it will be copied to this working directory.
Let's copy also got some there. So we copied
this now we can download them. So to download
them we need to run the command go mod download.
So with this all the packages that we will install
here, they will be downloaded also in the Docker
container. After that is finished, we have to copy
all of the files. So this dot means all the files
here, the second one will mean sir, all of the
files will be COVID copied to the working
directory. So once we copy everything we
run, go build in the output will be out
this so you can name the output as you want.
And it will learn on these files here. So we
can run that command also. Now so we can test
what it does generate. So we have out and
we have a distribution here that we can use.
So now that we have this, this the
exact executable, we run the command
which is simply out this, that's it. So you can
name it, whatever you want. I named it this.
And simply we will run this file and
I will go run go up will run. Okay,
one last thing that I will make which
all the backends needs to listen to Port
80. So I don't want to listen to Port 3000. I
will listen to Port 80. But this will be the
port inside the Docker container. So don't
worry if this conflicts to your browser.
So now that we have built everything, let's
run this. So to run this run Docker build,
we need to name the container I will name
the container up. So to Name the container,
we have to put minus d in front of it, then we
need to add dot here, which means that it will
search for this folder, and it will run
this Docker file. So let's build it. And
now it's building. So it will learn all these
commands. And let's wait till it's completed.
So everything was successfully built. And now
we can push this container to the cloud. But
before let's see on our browser, if
everything runs fine, so run Docker run,
we need to specify the port. So the port inside
the Docker container was ad. But in our local
host, we can put whatever port we want, I'll put
8888. And then we need the name of the container,
which we call it up. So as you can see, the fiber
up is running. And now if we go to localhost Port
8888, we'll see hello world here. So we
successfully build the production ready,
container for golang. And now let's push it to
the cloud. And I'll close this ID because we don't
need it anymore. In this video, we'll
create a Docker container for Roosevelt up
in the wall bushes that container to AWS,
Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
First, let's create a Docker file here. And,
of course, make sure to have installed the
Docker in your machine. And here, I will add
from not the version I will specify 15.4 here
and I will name it as build. So this will be
a multistage build. I will explain later this
as build what does this mean. And
let's add the working directory.
I will call it up. So this is the folder
that will create our project. You can name
it whatever you want. And then we'll copy package
that JSON to that folder. So we'll copy package
dot JSON dot means this working directory, a lot
of star here, which means that we'll get package
JSON and also package lock that Jason so we can
add anything in between the star. So now that we
are those are on npm install. Since we are from
a node environment, this MPM will be available.
And after npm install is finished. Let's copy
everything. So this is all these files and folders
to this working directory. So once
we add everything we have to build,
so run NPM run build. So this is the first
stage so we can run NPM run build here to see
what files does it generate. So this generates
a bundle dot j s here on the public folder.
So this is what we're gonna do.
So once this is generated here,
we don't need this other files. So we don't
need scripts SRC everything, so we need only
the public folder, we don't need even the node
modules. So that's why we do a multistage build.
So we can create another container here nginx the
version is one point 19. So this container now
we want get, we want to get only the public
folder. But first let's add here our directory
nginx and inside our create a file nginx.com.
And here, I will copy this code. So I'll provide
this code in the description of this video. And
we need to copy this file to copy nginx
nginx zatkoff to ATC nginx nginx.com. So
we added the configuration and now We named
this built, and we will copy from the built
in the app. So up is the working
directory, we want only the public folder.
So we got the public folder,
and we'll copy it to user.
Share nginx. html. So that's
it. So before it was all
this, it was a container with all these files. So
we don't need not models or all these files here.
Then we created a smaller container that contains
only the public folder with the bundle JS files.
With this, we can run our Docker container.
So let's create it. So to build this
Docker file we're on Docker build, we need to
specify the name for this Docker container. So
I'll put d minus d. Up. So up is a name that
I put so you can put whatever name you want.
And the.in. The end is we will build to
this context, and we'll get this Docker
file. And that's it. So this will build
our app. Let's wait till this completed.
So it is completed. And now this
container is ready to be pushed
to the cloud. But before let's test it on the
browser. So to run on the browser on Docker
run. And we have to specify the port output 8888.
And the port inside this Docker container is 80.
And the name of the container is up. So it started
and now in our browser, go to localhost Port 8888.
And we can see hello world and our belt up is
running. So with this, we are ready now to push
the container to the cloud and outlaws this ID
because we don't need it anymore. In this video,
we'll build a Docker container for the jungle
up. And we'll push that container to AWS,
Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
So first, I will create here, a Docker file.
So we need to start from Python. And the
version that I will put here is 3.9. Alpine. So
this container will have a Python pre installed
with this version. And also Alpine is the smallest
version of Linux. Let's add an environment
variable, which is Python. And buffered. Once this
is needed in order to see the logs in our Python
app, and now let's create a working directory. So
this you can name it whatever you want. All
the files will be added in this app folder.
Then we need to install the dependencies. So
I will add here a file called requirements
dot txt. And here, I will just add Django with
this version. So this is our only requirement.
And we need to copy that file to the working
directory. So this dot means this working
directory so we'll copy this file to the working
directory. And then we need to run the command PIP
installed minus R. I will copy the file here.
So this will list out all the dependencies
inside this container. Don't forget also once
you add the dependency to update, also your
requirements that txt once we install everything
will copy all the files. So we'll copy everything
here to this working directory. And that's
it. So in the end, we'll learn the command
Python manage that py run server output here the
host, it needs to be 0.0 point 0.0. So it should
be inside the Docker container. So this should
be the port, the host, and the port should be 80.
Why did I change the port to 80, because all our
containers in this project will learn on port 80.
And I'm reusing videos. So that's why
I put 80. But if you want, you can put
the normal Port 1000. So let's run this Docker
file to run this Docker file we have to build,
we have to build it first. So Docker build.
And we want to specify the name for this
container. So to specify a name, put minus d, I'll
call it up. And I will add the.in the end which
means it will build in this context, and it will
select this Docker file. Let's run it. And as we
see it's building. Let's wait through this
completed. So it is built. Now this container
can be pushed to the cloud. But before let's test
it on our browser. So to test it on our browser or
on Docker run, we need to specify a port. So for
the back for the container is a D as we thought.
And in our fronted in our browser, we can put
whatever port we want output 8888. In the end,
we need our container, which is up. Let's run
it. As you can see, our server is running. And
now we can go to our browser and type localhost
Port 8888. And this is our Django up running. So
the container is working fine. And now
we are ready to push it to the cloud.
I will also close the ID because we won't
use it anymore. In this video, we'll create
a Docker container for Laravel project. And
then we will push that Docker container to AWS,
Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
First of all, create here, a Docker file.
And of course make sure to have installed Docker
in your machine. And here in the Docker file,
we'll start from bhB the very version will be 7.4
FPM. So this is the container that will have PHP
already installed there. Still, we need to install
some other packages. I will base them here. So
these are some libraries that we need to install
in the VCs. The installation of composer because
composer is not already installed here.
And this is a command that will enable
these two extensions in our PHP dot INI file.
So that's it. After we add everything that
we need, let's specify the working directory. I'll
call it up, we need to copy composer that JSON to
the working directory. So this means that this
dot means that this composer that JSON will be
copied here. And after we got composer that JSON,
we need to run composer install. And we'll add no
scripts here. So we will simply
install everything that composer
needs. And we want around this post scripts like
this ones. So we will simply install everything
and after that, we will copy all the files
here into the working directory. So now we have
everything and we will simply run the command php
artisan serve, we need to specify also the host
which will be 0.0 point zero and also the port two
ad so we don't need to put the ad port here, but I
need it because I combine multiple video Yes, and
they all have Port 80. So we finished with Docker
file, now we are, we're ready to build it. So to
build this Docker file around Docker build, we
need to specify the name for this Docker build.
And we can specify a name by adding minus d, the
name, I'll put it up, but you can name it whatever
you want in the end dot min service contacts
here. And we do search for this Docker file.
So it will learn that Docker file, and now
is building Let's wait till it's completed.
So it is built. Now this container
is ready to be deployed on the cloud.
But before let's test it on our browser to see if
it works. So to run it on our browser or on Docker
around, we need to specify a port. So the
port inside the Docker container is ad.
And in our browser, you can put whatever port you
want output 8888. So in the end, we need the name
of our container, so we specified it to be up.
So this is our Docker run, and is running. So
if we go to the browser now and go to localhost
Port 8888, we'll see the Laravel app running so
the container is running fine. Now, let's push
this container to the cloud. Also, I'll close
this ID because we won't use it anymore.
This video will create a Docker container for
a dotnet project. And we'll push that project to
AWS, Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
First, in this web API, I will make just a small
change, I will remove this controller here. And
the route will be the empty route. And our app
will simply return the default weather. So that
is not important. What is important is to create
a new Docker file, so new file, Docker file.
So make sure also to we have installed Docker
in your machine. And let's start with from
we need to the image that we want to start. So
I will write Microsoft Azure Container Registry
microsoft.com slash dotnet. Slash SDK. So
we'll start with the version five. So this is
the container that will start and it will ever
instigate already installed in this container.
And I will name it as built. So this will be
a multistage Docker build. And I'll explain it
later why I name it like this. So let's start with
the working directory. I'll name it up for a week,
you can specify whatever folder that you want,
I will name it like this. And here, we'll copy
the C sharp project. So all
that C sharp project. So
like this, and we will copy to the working
directory. So this project will be copied to this
dot means this working directory and after it's
copied, we're on the command.net restore. After we
run the copy, that command will copy all in that
folder again. So this will get all the files here.
And it will copy it to the working directory. And
after we copied all the files, we need to publish
to a DLL. So to do it, we're on the command
run.net publish. We need to specify release
and into the output will be in the out folder.
And that's it for the first stage. So let's
run this command in our local machine to see
what this does generate. So If we run this
command, we will get an output folder here,
where we will have a lot of files. The one that
we are interested is this dotnet Docker DLL. So
we're interested only in this file, and we can
ignore all the other files. That's why we use now
a multistage build, because
this will contain all the files,
and also the output. But this other
container that we will build now, so from
all copy this dotnet. And we
will specify a ASP dotnet here.
This other container will live
the same working directory.
But don't confuse this working directory with
this one because there are different containers.
And we'll copy from the built from this build will
copy up, which is the working directory there.
out. So we'll copy everything in the out folder
to this dot, which is this working directory. So
we created another container with only
the out folder, so it is a smaller one.
And what is left is to add an entry
point.net and will execute.net
Docker DLL. And that's it. So in the end, we have
a lighter Docker container, which is just a DLL,
so we can execute it. So we finished with
this Docker file. Let's build it. So to
build a Docker file run Docker build. And we
want to specify a name for this Docker build.
And we can specify a name by adding minus d
up that is the name that we want to build.
And we will add the context which is
a.so. This will execute this Docker file.
So is building Let's wait to is completed.
So the container has been built. And now
we it is ready to be pushed to the cloud. But
before let's test it on our browser. to test it
on our browser, we have to run this container,
we need to specify the port. So inside of the
container, the port is 80. But in our localhost,
we can put whatever port we want output 8888.
Enter the name of our container
was up. So let's run this.
And it's successfully running now. So if we
open our browser, and right here, localhost Port
8888. We can see this is a JSON array that is
returning this weather forecast. So it's working
fine. So this container has been built. And now
we need to push it to the cloud. I will close
also this ID because we don't need it anymore.
In this video, we'll create a Docker container
for a kotlin app. And we'll push that container to
AWS, Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
First alder move here the test folder and the
in the resources I will add the server port
to AD so I want all the containers that I deployed
to run on port 80 because I'm reusing content,
but you can you may change it to the
port that you want doesn't matter. So,
I added the Port 80 and also I will add a
controller here. So a lot of directory controllers
in that will create a new kotlin file. So
home controller so this will be a class home
controller and it will have a function Home.
So let's add also a here, this
should be a rest controller.
Actually, I will paste
everything, so I don't want to
import it again. So this is our home
controller, it will be a rest controller,
it will have only one method that will return
hello world. So that's it. So this is simple.
And now we want to create a Docker container with
this simple app. So let's create a Docker file.
So first, make sure to have installed Docker
in your machine. And here I'll add from
we need the environment will be grayed out.
And the version will be seven, and the JDK
will be eight. So this is a version of that
of the gradel and dedicated, I want
to start all named this as built.
So this will be a multistage Docker build. I will
explain that later. Why I name it like that. But
let's focus first on this part. let's specify a
working directory, I'll call it up. So you can put
whatever name you want here. So all the
files will be created inside this folder now,
so let's copy everything there. So this
first.is all these files, and the second one is
this working directory. Once we added everything
there, we need to run the command dot flesh Gradle
W, we will execute this file built with the stack
trace. So this will generate a build folder here.
Let us see. So if I run Gradle w build here. This
will generate a builder folder. So as you can see,
we have a build folder now. So what
we want here is to go to the libs and
this is our jar that we want to execute. Actually,
I'll remove this snapshot to remove that snapshot,
we need to go to Gradle, build that gather that
kotlin to remove this. So this will create a
shorter name without the snapshot. So we don't
need to know any of these files, except for this
jar files. So that's why we created a model a
multistage built because now we can create another
container from openjdk. And this will be a smaller
one, we'll specify the same working directory. But
these are different containers. So don't worry if
they have the same name. We'll expose the Port 80
because we set it to our source folder, and
then we'll copy it from there builder will copy
this path. So up built lips. And then
we need the name of the file. So I will
copy this. But the we don't need the snapshot. So
we remove this snapshot. So it will be like this,
that jar. So this will be the name of the build.
And we'll copy it to this working directory.
And this container only has this jar
and we will just execute it so command
Java jar and then they will copy
this name. And that's it. So this is
a container. Let's start let's run it and test
it. So first we have to build it. So Docker
built. We need to specify the name for this Docker
build. And we can do that by adding minor step.
The name of the container will be up. So
we added this and then we need to add dot
which means So that it will be in this context,
and it will, it will execute this Docker file.
Let's run it. So I made a mistake. This is
built, I forgot a nail here. So now everything
is running. Let's wait till this is completed.
So it is completed. Now this container is ready
to be published to the cloud. But before let's
test it to our browser. To desert our browser,
we need to run the container. So Docker run, we
need to specify the port, so minus b, not D. and
the port inside the Docker container is 80. But
in our localhost, we can put whatever we want,
I will put 8888. And the name of the
container was up. If we run it like this,
it will execute it. So it's running fine. Now,
let's test it on the browser, localhost Port 8888.
We can see HelloWorld here, which means
our app is running fine. Now, let's
deploy this app to the cloud. And I will close
this ID because we don't need it anymore.
In this video, we'll create a Docker container
for a demo up, and we'll push it to AWS,
Google Cloud and Azure. So let's get started.
So make sure first to have installed Dino.
And I will simply copy this code. I'll create in
an empty directory here, a file that yes, and I
will paste this code. So this is a really simple,
if we run this up, then around of the tears,
we need also to add the allow net flag.
And as we can see, it's running
on port 8000. So if we go here,
localhost Port 8000. We'll see Hello,
world. So this is our demo app that we will
push. And let's start now
by creating a Docker file.
Make sure also you have Docker installed in
your machine. So this will be super simple.
We need to come from dental land. They're not the
latest version kerlin currently is one point 11.0.
And we have to specify a working directory
up. And then we'll copy everything
there. So this command means that the will
copy of the DS to this working directory. And
what is left is to Sibley around the
command that we just ran before, which is
we don't need to specify they're not but we
will around. We'll add the flag. Allow. net
and the file is up that yes. And that's it super
simple. Also, I will change something here.
I want to serve it to Port 1000. But I want
to serve it to Port 80. Because all our Docker
containers will server on port 80. And it's easier
for me to combine these tutorials, but you can
put the Port 1000 it's totally okay. Now that we
have everything, let's run this Docker file, first
we have to build it. So to build it around Docker
build, we want we need the name of the container.
So we specified by minus D and will specify the
name of the container to be up and then we'll
add a dot here which means it is this context and
it will select this Docker file. So let's build
up now it is building it will be fast once he's
done loading everything. So it is completed. Now
we can push this container to the cloud. But
before let's test it again to our browser.
And to test it, we have to run it. So Docker
run. This time, we have to specify a port
and the back end port. So the container port
is 80, as we said, and in the front end,
we can put 8888 not in the
front and in our localhost.
And then we have to specify the name
of our container. So this is a command
to run this container to Port 8888.
So it's downloading again, because
it's running inside the container and
not sure why it has this problem. Now.
After I run it again, it worked. Not
sure why it failed the first time.
And it says a localhost ad here, but
that is inside the Docker container.
Our localhost now, eight 1000 won't work as we
see. But our port now is 8888. And now we can
see Hello word. Now this HelloWorld is running
inside the Docker container. And that's it, we
completed the Docker container for this demo up.
Now, let's push it to the cloud. I'll also close
this ID because we don't need it anymore. So I'm
logged in now to my AWS Management Console. And we
will push now our Docker container to the elastic
Container Registry. So I have a shortcut here,
or we can search it. So let's go to the Container
Registry. And this is a Container Registry.
Let's see the repositories so we don't have any
repositories or registries, we have to create one.
So we will push our Docker container here to have
our read repository. First, before we do anything,
make sure to install the AWS COI, so go to AWS
amazon.com slash c li. And on the right side here,
you can download the Windows version of Mac
OS version or the Linux version. So with this,
you will have access to your terminal to AWS
and you have several commands that you can use.
So now let's first log into elastic Container
Registry by using this command. So AWS
ECR is elastic Container Registry. This is
the command to log in. This is the region
region US East two pipe Docker
login is the username will be AWS,
the password, we it will be generated by this one.
So that's why his password SD, and this other URL
is like this is our user ID. So we can find that,
if we go to our account you we have the ID here.
So that's it. And the Docker dot ECR, this
is also the same region in Amazon aws.com.
Let's run this command. And we successfully logged
in. And now what is left is to push out Docker
container to the elastic Container Registry. So to
do that, we have to do Docker dog, the name of our
container was up. And I will copy again this URL.
So we have to target to this URL slash in the end
up so the name should be the same here and this
URL will use it a lot. So let's target this.
And after we target we have to push it. So remove
tug to push. And let's wait till it's completed.
So we get an error that repository with name up
does not exist. So let's create it. We are here at
the repositories and let's create a repository.
So this is the same URL And it will be up. So
I'm just checking region if it is the
same. So this will be a private repository.
This is the repository name. And I will leave
the others by default, let's create this
repository. And we created it. So let's push
our image now, not here, here, Docker push.
And now it's pushing. So this will take some time,
and the image will be pushed to the repository.
So our image has been pushed. So if we go to
our repository, we have one latest image here,
the size and everything else. So we have our image
in our repository. I will copy the URL right here
for the repository, because we will need it.
And now let's go to Amazon Container Service,
elastic Container Service ECS. And here, go to
the clusters, and we'll create a cluster. So
I will select the AWS fargate cluster, because it
will take care of the managing of the server for
us. If you want to manage your server,
select this other one. But this is way
easier if we select the AWS fargate. So
let's go next, the cluster name, so my up
and I will create a default
VPC VPC for this cluster. And
I want to select anything else. Let's create
it. And let's wait till this is completed.
So the cluster is created, click View cluster.
And now we need the task definition. So go to task
definitions. And let's create a new task
definition. So I'll select fargate. Next step,
the task definition name, I'll call
it up the role, I'll select None.
And the network model, select the default.
And for the task memory, 0.5 gigabytes,
the CBO. So I'll select the minimal versions. And
the container here we need to add the container
that we just copied. So this container and
the container name, it will be also up here
we need to set up the port. So 80 was the port
inside the container. So we have to map it here.
And we can add all of our configurations.
But I won't add any thought.
Let's add this. And we added our container there.
And that's it basically let's create this task
definition. So it was successful. And now let's
go to our cluster. And here, now we can create
our service. So this will be also a fargate we
need the task definition that we created. So
Amazon will automatically assign it we need the
service name. So up so we have a lot of ups with
names number of tasks, I will select one but you
can select two it will create two containers.
One it will be only one container.
So I will keep everything minimal,
but you can select two and everything should
be okay now. So let's go to the next step
subnets I'll select the one of these
options and also assign a public IP Yes,
load balancer I will select None. And the next
step Oh, here we can auto scale but since this
is an example I will not auto scale. So it will be
just a simple container. Review create service. So
everything is created. So let's go to
the View service. And let's click here.
And the status is pending. Let's wait till is
running and then after it's done. We will have
a public IP, which we will see it. Let's wait.
So our task is running now. And we have a public
IP for it. So I'll copy this IP, or visit here.
And this is our app. So this is how we deploy
a Docker container to AWS fargate. Thank you for
watching this video. Don't forget to like, share,
and subscribe. Thank you. So I'm logged into my
azuro portal here. And before I create anything,
make sure to have installed the Azores ccli.
So download the right version for your machine
and follow the instructions, you will have access
to this is the command which it will show these
options. So before let's go back to the Azure
portal. And we'll create a Container Registry. So
we don't have any Container Registry yet.
So let's create a Container Registry. So
I'll create the Container Registry here, the
resource group, I have a demo demo resource group
here, which I gather just the name. The registry
name, I'll call it up. So it needs to have
five characters, so I will call it my
up. Oh, already news for my container.
Okay, container up. So which name is not used.
So my container up, I will use this name. And
for location, you can pick your location for
this SKU, I will select the basic version.
Let's create it. And we can create
this registry. And now that we created
our registry, we need also to log in. So
first, we have to log in via USB or like this
is the login. So we need to sign into our account
here. And we logged in to MC soft Azure. So as
you can see, it shows this data. So after we log
in there, we have to run this other command. So
as your as your Container Registry login, and
here we need the name, which was which was
up. So let's copy it also forgot to the resource.
And let's copy the URL, which is this one. So
we don't need the suffix.
So let's log in. So this will allow us to
push a Docker container to ashore. So we
successfully logged in. And now that we logged in,
we can push our image to push our image. First,
we have to talk the image. So Docker tag, the
name of our container is up. And I'll paste again,
this URL, which I copied. And do we need to add
Indian slash up. So this is our repository here.
So I gather this. And after we tag, we have to
push it. So let's push it. And now it's pushing
our container to it as your Container
Registry. So let's wait till this completed.
So it is completed. Now we can go back. And
here we'll go to the repositories. This is our
upper repository. And here we have our image.
So this is our image. And what I will do here
is I will copy this container name, so I'll
copy this. And let's go back to home. And
let's create a container instance now.
So let's create a container instance.
I'll select the same resource group. We
need the container name. The container name
is up And we have to select the image
source to zero Container Registry.
And we have our container app. So we need to
enable admin here. So let's click learn more. And
we have to run this command. So I will copy this
command. And I will run it here. So we need the
name here, or our ID directly. Not
sure if we need my container up.
So I made the mistake here, it
should be with one m, not two M's.
So it is enabled. And now we can use it. So do
we need to refresh here, I will refresh. And I
will select this resource group, I'll select
up here, registry, and now it is selected. So
everything is correct, I'll change the size
here, I will keep everything minimal. So
point five is minimal. memory. So
I'll select this, review and create.
Also, I think, Oh, I forgot something. So
we need to also go to the networking part.
And we have to map the Port 80. So by default is
automatically mapped, so we don't have anything to
change. But if your container port is different,
we need to select here, the the other port, so
ad is correctly. And we don't need to
change anything else. Let's create it.
So deployment is in progress. The deployment
is complete. So let's go to the resource.
And we have a public IP address here. So we
can copy this IP address. And if we go to
the IP address, we can see our app deployed.
So this is how we deploy a Docker container
to a zoo content container instance. Thank you for
watching this video, I hope you like share, and
subscribe. Thank you. So I'm logged into my Google
Cloud Platform now. And we will we will use two
services Container Registry and cloud run.
So let's go to the Container Registry.
And before adding anything here, we need to
install the Google Cloud SDK. So make sure
to download the right installer for Mac OS, you
don't load it here, also for Windows and Linux,
and also make sure to add it to your path.
Once it is completed, you can use G Cloud.
So I already have my G Cloud configured. And
now let's log in first. So in order to push
containers to the Google Cloud registry, we have
to be logged in first. So G Cloud, our login. So
this will connect with our Google Cloud
account. And we will allow everything.
And now we are logged in. If we go
to our terminal, we will see this so
I'll clear it now. And now we can push our image
to a Docker registry to the Container Registry
story. So first, we have to tag the image.
So Docker tag, the name of the image is up.
And we will target to Google Cloud registry.
So gcr.io slash we need the project name. So
if we go to our cloud platform, click our
project here. And this is my project name. So
I'll copy this ID here. And I will add it here. So
this is our project ID. And then we need the name
of our container. So this should
be the same with the last one. I
talked about this and then we need to push
it so I'll remove this and we'll push it
and this will Push the container to our Google
Cloud Platform. So let's wait till is completed.
So the image is pushed. Now, we will see the
image here. So in the Container Registry,
we have our app image. And let's go here and let's
copy the URL. So I'll copy the URL here. Because
we will need it. And let's go down now to the
cloud run. So here, we need to create a service.
When you add the service name, I'll call it
up the region, you can select your own region,
we need the container image URL.
So here, we can select it directly.
And this is the container, the last
container that we pushed. So select this.
And this was our container. We cannot some
advanced settings here like variable secrets,
etc. But the only thing that we will change
is the port. So our container port is 80. So
I'll put ad here. And we don't need to change
anything else there. Next. So we need to allow
an unauthenticated invocations. So this is
public. And that's it. So let's create this.
And let's wait till it's completed. So
it should be fast. So it is completed,
not sure why I made a mistake here. The port was
76. Here, it should be 80. And we have also a URL
here. If we go to the URL, we'll see our app
deployed. So it was this simple. This is how
we deploy an app to the Google Cloud run. Don't
forget to like, share and subscribe. Thank you